I'll say this is radio lab, the podcast,
and you take it from there. Ready?
All right. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab,
the BOD pod. Let me say, okay, sorry.
This is radio lab, the podcast.
Damn you, come on. No,
he's like, you know what,
actually this is a sort of appropriate
because we will want to talk about
sharing right now. I,
that's all I was doing and I was
trying to share the moment with you
unsuccessfully. But so our
last hour was all about, uh,
trying to solve the puzzle of
why is there niceness in a very,
very cruel doggy dog world.
Why would there be any kind
of sharing your niceness?
And as we asked the scientist in the show,
which we call the good show this way,
he just kept saying over
and over again, well,
oftentimes what you would call nice
behavior is actually disguised selfishness
as critters of one kind or another.
Try to push their genes into the future
by being nice to particular folks,
to their sisters, to
their cousins, to others,
and to those who are from their family,
which share so many of their
genes like according to some,
like a real hard ass biologist could
argue if you're nice to your sister,
you're really just being nice to your
own jeans in another person's body.
And we were like, Huh, yeah. Is there
another way of thinking about this?
And so we met a guy, my
name is Jerry Wilkinson.
I'm a professor and chair of the
Department of biology at the University of
Maryland College Park.
And the story that Jerry told us happened
way before he was a chair or anything
like that when he was
a lowly Grad student.
The first summer of my graduate
education I went to Costa Rica.
This was the summer of 1977
we went all over the country.
You've studied various things and we
had an opportunity to apply for money to
stay in Costa Rica and
do individual projects.
And Jerry decided what he was
going to study. Where bats,
why bats have you always liked that?
I'd never actually handled the bat before
I went to Costa Rica so I had no prior
experience whatsoever and I was like
anyone I think may be a little bit uh,
hesitant I guess,
but he says he just happened to be in
this place that had a lot of bats cause I
was on a cattle ranch otherwise
known as the McDonald's of a
yes because there's something we haven't
told you here. These were vampire bats,
the common vampire bat,
which feeds primarily on Mammalian blood
and these particular batch Jerry's has
lived down by the river in
hollow trees, big ones inside.
They were like Kate threes along the
rivers and every night he says hundreds of
these bats would fly out of their trees,
kind of like a cloud
move across the fields,
hitting towards cow herd.
Basically they will hop up
onto a cow, sink their teeth,
razor sharp teeth into the cow's
neck and start sucking its blood.
And in a matter of about a half an hour,
they basically swell up like a big
tick and fly home to the tree quickly.
Then they come back the trees. Anyhow,
what Jerry was really interested in was
not so much the cow split sucking thing.
It was how do the bats
behave with each other? Yeah,
so one morning he went down to
the river where these bats live,
found himself a tree. These trees,
some of them were so big that I could
actually lie down inside the tree without
bending my knees.
We would use binoculars to look
up at the top of the cavity,
which could be anywhere from 15
feet to 40 feet above the ground.
Now picture this, you're in the street.
It's four stories high. It's dark,
it's wet and up at the
top. How many are up there?
Maybe 20 would be sort of some of
the larger groups. What about poop?
Weren't they pooping on you because
you write in the direct line? Yes.
They do that and it's sort of like
tar. When they defecate blood,
it's very sticky, but day after
day he would go into these trees,
get pooped on and watch them.
Pretty soon he starts to notice that
these bats are behaving in ways he really
didn't expect.
They behave quite a bit like primates,
meaning what? They spend a lot
of time grooming each other.
Really 30% of the time in the trees
they spend grooming each other. Huh.
So there you were looking
at these reputedly evil
creatures and seeing them kind
of snuggle. I mean, were you
surprised by this? Oh yeah.
Took me no time at all
to become very fond,
I guess would be the best way to
describe it. They are very social.
They're very interactive.
But then Jerry saw one of
the dudes something, um,
that went way beyond just being social.
You know, it's, it's hard to say.
Certainly it not a single observation,
but basically here's how it would go.
One Bat.
One Bat will sort of sidle up to another
bat and give her a little hug and they
sort of clutch each other with
their wings, which are folded up.
And then the bat that made the
move, it came up and gave the hug.
You'd see that bat try the lick
at the mouth of the other bat.
The one it's hugging. And
if you have a good view,
you can actually see the tongue of one
bat going into the mouth of the other
bat. Like they're giving each
other a kiss. Very similar. Yes.
But after seeing this a few times,
he realized what really was happening is
that the one bat was feeding the other
bat. Yes. Giving it a meal
by regurgitating blood
into the other bats mouth.
And that was a shock.
A shock because, well,
these weren't moms feeding their babies.
I mean that we've all
seen and that makes sense.
Now these were adult animals
eating other adult animals,
food that they could've been eating
themselves. Right. Just weird.
That had not been described before.
There's any thought we didn't need a
second. I know what's going on here.
What? These bats, they're just
related. Correct. Their relatives.
Close relatives. Yeah.
The idea that was in vogue
then and is still in vogue now,
and certainly it's actually got much
more support now than it did then,
is that animals tend to help close
relatives and sort of never help anybody
who's not a close relative. So we
thought that must be it. They're related,
but you don't just assume it. You
must test it if you're a scientist.
So Jerry did, okay, I'm
going to check this out.
I'm going to set up a
little experiment. Yes.
So he went out and got a bunch of
bats that he knew were not related.
Like I had two groups
of six total of 12 bats,
brought them into my house at the
time, went to slaughter house,
got a lot of blood,
and then every night I would take one of
the 12 bats out of the cage and not let
it feed while everybody
else got access to blood,
which means this sad
little bag. It's no dinner,
but it has to watch the others eat.
And it's just getting
hungrier and hungrier. Well,
how long can a bat go with no
blood? Three days at most, at most,
and then they're dead. So you can
imagine that by the time the sun rises,
this bat is literally
starving. And then at dawn,
I would put the female
back in who hadn't fed.
She will go and beg
from other individuals.
And weirdly, instead of them saying to
her, you're not my sister, I'll go off.
Yeah. According to Jerry,
what would happen is that they in hold
still part their lips and throw up in her
mouth.
[inaudible]
thank you.
I mean at that point I was thrilled that
I had found something that seemed to
indicate that there, it wasn't
just all about relatedness,
just to make sure this wasn't a fluke.
What I then did over the span of the
next two weeks as I continued to take one
bat out of the cage every night and you'd
do the whole starver Tilden thing and
then put her back in the cage with the
others and she was always [inaudible]
[inaudible]
and by someone from her group,
and occasionally even by more than
one individual from her group,
sometimes one bat will step up
and say, okay, have something.
And then maybe another, sometimes
a third, and he's talking question,
I wonder what's going on here. Is this
random or is there some kind of system?
He, he just couldn't really tell.
So then I just kept track of who
fed home while I was there. I was,
you know, staying up all night.
I wasn't really doing a lot of analysis
of the information and I was only there
for a relatively short period.
I got back up to San Diego,
did the analysis and discovered that
there appeared to be, to be a pattern.
If, um, you know,
Sally Fed Agnes on the first day
and then I later starved Sally,
then Agnes fed Sally on the second night.
Right. Let's just go
through this one more time.
If on the first day Sally fed Agnes,
then on the second day
Agnes fed Sally invariably,
not always, but invariably,
and what is invariably mean in that
most of the time, most of the time,
most of the time. So if I'm Agnes,
I'm only going to feed Sally under the
condition that at some later point in
time she will repay the favor. I see you,
you feed me Agnes seeds,
Sally, Sally feeds.
And if you think about it that
this is kind of what friendship is.
I mean we never say that explicitly,
but friendship works on these kinds
of trees. I'm going to be Pete, Cindy,
Cindy feet, Mindy. In variably,
in fact with the bats,
Gerry at a certain point created a kind
of matrix that lotted who had spent time
with whom the friendships
between the individual bets.
And that allowed me to actually
calculate a number that measured,
you know, who was the best friends and
who were the not such good friends.
Like a friend number. Yes.
Who was this? So eighth grade.
And it turns out that number is the
best predictor of who will feed him.
It's better than who's
related to better. Yes.
Although it turned out that
they both were important. So,
but I want to write a headline around
this. You're saying that, that,
that that buddies beat kin.
Yes. Yes. I'll go with this beans if, if,
if friends can beat family
than if be first of all,
have friends or people
that you choose. Yeah.
I mean you've stuck with your family,
but you can choose your friends.
That's in effect an idea that niceness
is really deeply chosen. Yeah.
Well. So what is the, so
what is w in the, in the, uh,
in the broad scientific
community, does this,
does this mean what you counted
and saw open up altogether?
Again, the question of
who helps who and why?
Uh,
ah, yes, but now we're talking 1984,
that's when this work was published
and the Hoe, that's when the sort of,
and I gave talks about it various places.
So it became well known pretty quickly
and, and it was a really big deal.
In fact, some scientists thought maybe
this is going to revolutionize our whole
understanding of niceness and nature and
social dynamics and creatures because
you know, maybe this behavior
isn't just a bad thing.
It's everywhere and we just
haven't been seeing it.
We haven't been working
hard enough to see it.
Like this Jerry Guy slept in a tree
got pooped on for weeks on end.
Maybe if we pushed ourselves that far,
we'd find this all over the place.
But no, didn't work out that way.
There are not many convincing cases that
I think people identified in those next
few years. So the observation
you're making may not be large,
just may be writ small.
Um, yeah. Well
I'm not sure I would
describe it exactly that way,
but clearly it's how much
we can extrapolate the
Vampyr event story to other
systems is an open
question and well in your,
in your most extrapolated frame of mind,
maybe when you were sitting in a bar and
your three Martinis in and in your gut
and your drunk gut at that
moment, what is your hunch?
Is this a representative case and we
just haven't found it elsewhere but we
will? Or is this a one off? Oh,
I don't think it's unique, but
I don't think it's very common.
I think it would be quite
uncommon. You know, they have,
our vets are really pretty special
because of this reliance on blood.
Here's one story you could tell.
It says Jerry way back in the day,
40,000 or more years in the past,
the planes where the bats lived were
filled with all of these giant creatures.
Big mammals were abundant.
Saber Tooth Tigers,
mammoth wolves,
then giant slaws and all of these
things were filled with warm blood.
So the bats were very happy.
But presumably there was a point in
time when all of these large mammals is
appeared really fast and there all kinds
of theories as to why that happened.
The point is it must have created a time
when vampire bats all of a sudden had a
hard time finding prey.
At that point I would think it would have
been behoove a vampire bat to come up
with some way to deal with periodic food
Georges and he thinks the strategy they
came up with somehow somehow was to share.
If they didn't help each other,
I think you would find vampire bats gone.
I mean we wouldn't see them. Um, now,
well this is interesting.
This is a new way to explore the question
we've been exploring all this time and
they show their niceness in the
world. Yeah, no. Up to now we thought,
well mostly niceness is a
secret form of selfishness,
selfishness, selfishness,
Dean's into the future. Yeah.
But this is a different version.
This one says, you know,
under certain circumstances
for a group of animals,
being nice really isn't an option. It's
the only way. Yeah. Like when the
going gets tough, the tough get.
Nice. How's that for a bumper sticker?